Hi,
I'm in the dressing room at the Palace
Theater in Louisville,
Kentucky on June 14th,
2018,
and I thought I'd read you an excerpt
from maps of meaning the architecture of
belief,
which is a book I published in
[inaudible] Ninety nine with routledge
and it's been the basis of my youtube
lectures and I would say also 12 rules
for life,
a lot of the ideas and 12 rules for
life.
Her first worked out with maps of
meaning by just recorded an audio
version of the book was released two
days ago,
June twelfth,
2018 and it's available from penguin
books on audible.
I'll put the links in the description of
the video.
I'm hoping that the audio version with
its careful intonation will be easier to
understand.
Maps of meaning is a rather difficult
book.
Um,
in any case,
I'm going to read you an excerpt from it
today and that'll serve as a bit of an
introduction to the book.
I'll make some more excerpts over the
next coming weeks I think as well,
but we'll start with this one.
I was reading Jeffrey Burton,
Russell's Mephistopheles the devil in
the modern world.
When I came across his discussion of
dusty huskies,
the brothers Karamazov Russell Discusses
Ivan's argument for Atheism,
which is one of the most powerful ever
mounted.
Ivan is one of the brothers and the
brothers Karamazov Ivan's examples of
evil all taken from the daily newspapers
of 18,
76 are unforgettable.
The nobleman who orders is hounds to
tear the peasant boy to pieces in front
of his mother,
the man who whips his struggling horse
on its gentle eyes,
the parents who lock their tiny daughter
all night in the freezing privy while
she knocks on the walls,
pleading for mercy,
the Turk who entertains a baby with a
shiny pistol before blowing his brains
out.
Ivan knows that such horrors occur daily
and can be multiplied without end.
I took the case of children.
Ivan explains to make my case clearer of
the other tiers with which the earth is
soaked.
I will say nothing.
Burton Russell's states the relation of
evil to God has in the century of
Auschwitz and Hiroshima once again
become center of Philosophical and
theological discussion.
The problem of evil can be stated
simply,
God is omnipotent.
God is perfectly good.
Such a God would not permit evil to
exist,
but we observed that evil exists,
therefore God does not exist.
Variations on this theme are nearly
infinite.
The problem is not only abstract and
philosophical.
Of course,
it is also personal and immediate.
Believers tend to forget that they're
god takes away everything that one cares
about possessions,
comforts,
success,
professional craft knowledge,
friends,
family and life.
What kind of God is this?
Any decent religion must face this
question squarely and no answer is
credible that cannot be given in the
face of dying children.
It seems to me that we use the horrors
of the world to justify our own
inadequacies.
We make the presumption that human
vulnerability is a sufficient cause of
human cruelty.
We blame God and God's creation for
twisting and perverting our souls and
claim all the time to be innocent
victims of circumstance.
What do you say to a dying child?
You say you can do it.
There is something in you that is strong
enough to do it and you don't use the
terrible vulnerability of children as an
excuse for the rejection of existence
and the perpetration of conscious evil.
When I wrote maps of meaning,
I did not have much experience as a
clinical psychologist to have my
patients,
however stayed in my mind.
The first was a woman about 35 years
old.
She looked 50.
She reminded me of a medieval peasant of
my conception of a medieval peasant.
She was dirty clothes,
hair,
teeth,
dirty with the kind of fill that takes
months to develop.
She was unbearably shy.
She approached anyone who she thought
was superior in status to her,
which was virtually everyone hunched
over with her eyes,
shaded by her hands,
both hands as if she could not tolerate
the light emanating from her target.
She had been in behavioral treatment in
a Montreal hospital before as an
outpatient and was in fact a site known
to the permanent staff at the clinic.
Others had tried to help her overcome
her unfortunate manner of self
presentation,
which made people on the streets shy
away from her,
made them regard her as crazy and
unpredictable.
She could learn to stand or sit up
temporarily with eyes unguarded,
but she reverted to her old habits as
soon as she left the clinic,
she may have been intellectually
impaired and consequences of some
biological fault.
It was difficult to tell because her
environment was so appalling.
It may have caused her ignorance.
She was illiterate as well.
She lived with her mother whose
character I knew nothing about and with
an elderly desperately ill bedridden,
and her boyfriend was a violent
alcoholic.
Schizophrenia who mistreated her
psychologically and physically,
who was always muddling simple mind with
tirades about the devil and the worship
of Satan.
She had nothing going for her.
No beauty,
no intelligence,
no loving family,
no skills,
no employment,
nothing.
She didn't come to therapy to resolve
her problems.
However,
nor to unburden her soul,
nor to describe her mistreatment and
victimization at the hands of others.
She came.
She came because she wanted to do
something for someone who is worse off
than her.
The clinic where I was interning was
associated with a large psychiatric
hospital.
All of the patients that still remained
after the shift to community care in the
aftermath of the sixties were so
incapacitated that they could not
survive on the streets.
She had done some volunteer work,
have some limited type in that hospital
and decided that she could maybe be
friend,
a patient,
take him or her outside for a walk.
I think she got this idea because she
had a dog when she walked regularly and
when she liked to take care of.
All she wanted from me was help
arranging this,
help finding someone who she could take
outside,
help finding someone in the hospital
bureaucracy who would allow this to
happen.
I was not very successful in aiding her,
but she didn't seem to hold that against
me.
It is said that one piece of evidence
that runs contrary to a theory is
sufficient to disprove that theory.
Of course,
people do not think this way and perhaps
should not,
in general theory is to useful,
to give up easily to difficult to
regenerate and the evidence against
should be consistent and believable
before it is accepted,
but the existence of this woman made me
think she was destined for a
psychopathological end from the
viewpoint of biological and
environmental determinism faded as
surely as anyone I had ever met and
maybe she beat her dog sometimes and was
rude to her sick and maybe I never saw
her vindictive or unpleasant even when
her simple wishes were thornton.
I don't want to say that she was a saint
because I didn't know her well enough to
tell,
but the fact was that in her misery and
simplicity,
she remained without self pity and able
to see outside of herself.
Why wasn't she a criminal,
cruel,
unbalanced,
and miserable.
She had every reason to be,
and yet she wasn't in her simple way.
She had made the proper choices.
She remained bloody but unbowed,
and she seemed to me rightly or wrongly,
to be a symbol of suffering humanity
solely afflicted,
yet capable of courage and love.
God
justifies his creation in Milton's
paradise lost
such I created all the theory,
powers and spirits,
both them who stood and them who failed,
not free.
What proof could they have given sincere
of true allegiance,
constant faith or love.
We're only what they needs must do,
appeared,
not what they would.
What praise could they receive?
What pleasure I from such obedience paid
when will and reason,
reason also his choice,
useless and vein of freedom.
Both despoiled made passive.
Both had served necessity,
not me.
They therefore has to write belonged,
so we're created nor can justly accused
there maker or they're making or their
fate as if predestination overruled
there will dispose by absolute decrease
or high for knowledge.
They themselves decreed their own
reformed,
nor I if I for new,
for knowledge,
has no influence on their fault which
had no less proved,
certain unfair known,
so without least impulse or shouting or
fade or art by me.
Immutably foreseen they trespass authors
to themselves in all both what they
judge and what they choose for.
So I formed them free and free.
They must remain until they throw
themselves.
I must change their nature and revoke
the high decrease,
unchangeable,
eternal which ordain their freedom.
They themselves or Dane their fall.
The other patient I wish to describe
what's the schizophrenia in a small
inpatient ward at a different hospital.
He was about 29 when I met him a few
years older than I was at the time and
had been in and out of confinement for
seven years.
He was of course on anti psychotic
medication and participated in
occupational therapy activities on the
ward,
making coasters and pencil holders and
so on,
but he could not maintain attention for
any amount of time.
It was not even much good at craft.
My supervisor asked me to administer an
intelligence test to him.
The standard wastes are more for the
sake of my experience than for any
possible diagnostic.
Good.
I gave my patients some of the red and
white blocks that made up the block
design subtests.
He was supposed to arrange the blocks,
so they matched a pattern printed on
some cards.
He picked them up and started to
rearrange them on the desk in front of
him.
Well,
I timed him stupidly with a stopwatch.
The task was impossible for him.
Even at the simplest of stages.
He looked constantly distracted and
frustrated.
I asked what's wrong?
He said,
the battle between good and evil in
heaven is going on in my hand,
and
I stopped the testing.
At that point,
I didn't know exactly what to make of
his comment.
He was obviously suffering and the
testing seem to make it worse.
What was he experiencing?
He wasn't lying,
that's for sure.
In the face of such a statement.
It seemed ridiculous to continue.
I spent some time with him that summer.
I'd never met someone who was so
blatantly mentally ill.
We talked on the ward and occasionally I
would take him for a walk through the
hospital grounds outside.
He was the third son of first generation
immigrants.
His first born brother was a lawyer.
The other physician,
his parents were obviously ambitious for
their children,
hardworking and disciplined.
He had been a graduate student working
towards a degree in immunology.
They don't precisely remember.
His brothers had sent him a daunting
example and he felt pressured to succeed
his experimental work and not turned out
as he had expected,
however,
and he apparently came to believe that
it might not graduate,
not at least when he had hoped to,
so he faked his experimental results and
wrote up his thesis.
Anyway,
he told me that the night he finished
writing,
he woke up and saw the devil standing
over him at the foot of his bed.
This event triggered the onset of his
mental illness from which he had never
recovered.
It might be said that the satanic
apparition merely accompanied the
expression of some pathological stress
induced neuro development whose
appearance was biologically
predetermined or the devil was merely
personification of his culture.
His conception of moral evil manifesting
itself in imagination as a consequence
of his guilt.
Both of these levels of description have
their merits,
but the fact remains that he saw the
devil and that division accompanied or
even was the event that destroyed him.
He was afraid to tell me much of his
fantasy and it was only after I had paid
careful attention to him that he opened
up.
He was not bragging or trying to impress
me.
He was terrified about what he believed,
terrified as a consequence of the
fantasies that impressed themselves upon
him.
He told me that he could not leave the
hospital because someone was waiting to
shoot him.
A typical paranoid delusion.
Why did someone want to kill him?
Well,
he was hospitalized during the Cold War,
not at its height perhaps,
but still during a time when the threat
of purposeful nuclear annihilation
seemed more plausible or likely than it
does now.
Many of the people I knew used the
existence of this threat to justify to
themselves their failure to participate
fully in life,
a life which they thought of
Romantically as doomed and therefore as
pointless,
but there were some real terror in the
pose and the thought of the countless
missiles pointed here and there around
the world,
sap,
the energy and faith of everyone
hypocritical or not,
my schizophrenia patient believed that
he was in fact the incarnation of the
world.
Annihilating force that he was destined
upon his release from the hospital to
make his way south to a nuclear missile
silo on American territory that he was
faded to make the decision that would
launch the final war.
The people outside the hospital knew
this and that is why they were waiting
to shoot him.
He did not want to tell me this story
and consequence,
although he did because he thought that
I might then want to kill him to my
friends in graduate school.
Thought it ironic that I had contact
with a patient of this type,
my peculiar interest in young and
young's ideas regarding the collective
unconscious.
We're well known to them and it seemed
to absurdly fitting that I would end up
talking to someone with delusions of
this type,
but I didn't know what to do with his
ideas.
Of course they were crazy and they had
done in my patient,
but it still seemed to me that they were
true from the metaphorical viewpoint.
His story in totality linked is
individual choice between good and evil
with the cumulative horror then facing
the world.
History implied that because he had
given into temptation at a critical
juncture,
he was in fact responsible for the
horror of the potential of nuclear war,
but how could this be?
It seemed insane to me to even consider
that the act of one powerless individual
could be linked in some manner to the
outcome of history as a whole,
but I am no longer so sure.
I've read much about evil and its manner
of perpetration and growth and I'm no
longer convinced that each of us are so
innocent,
so harmless.
It is of course a logical to presume
that one person,
one speck of dust amongst $6 billion
moats is any sense responsible for the
horrible course of human events,
but that course in itself is not logical
far from it and it seems likely that it
depends on processes that we do not
understand.
The most powerful arguments for the
nonexistence of God,
at least a good God are predicated on
the idea that such a being would not
allow for the existence of evil in its
classical natural diseases.
Disasters or moral war pogroms forms.
Such arguments can be taken further even
than atheism can be used to dispute the
justice of the existing world itself.
Dostoevsky states,
perhaps the entire cosmos is not worth a
single innocent child suffering.
How can the universe be constructed such
that pain is permitted?
How can a good God allow for the
existence of a suffering world?
These difficult questions can be
addressed in part as a consequence of
careful analysis of evil.
First,
it seems reasonable to insist upon the
value of the natural slash moral
distinction.
The tragic circumstances of life should
not be placed in the same category as
willfully undertaken.
Harm.
Tragedy,
subjugation to the mortal conditions of
existence has an ennobling aspect,
at least in potential and has been
constantly exploited to that end in
great literature and mythology.
True evil by contrast is anything but
normal.
Participation in Alex whose sole purpose
is expansion of innocent pain and
suffering destroys character forthright
encounter with tragedy by contrast may
increase it.
This is the meaning of the Christian
myth of the crucifixion.
It is Christ's full participation in and
freely chosen acceptance of his fate,
which he shares with all mankind.
That enables him to manifest his full
identity with God at it is that identity
which enables them to bear that fate and
which strips it of evil.
Conversely,
it is the voluntary demeaning of our own
characters which makes the necessary
tragic conditions of existence appear
evil,
but why is life tragic?
Why are we subject to unbearable
limitation to pain,
disease,
and death to cruelty at the hands of
nature and society?
Why do terrible things happen to
everyone?
These are of course unanswerable
questions,
but they must be answered somehow.
If we are able to face our own lives,
the best I can make of it is this.
This has helped me.
Nothing can exist without preconditions.
Even a game can be played without rules
and the rules say what cannot be done as
much as what can perhaps the world is
not possible as a world without its
borders.
Without its rules,
maybe existence wouldn't be possible in
the absence of our painful limitations.
Think of it this way.
If we could have everything wanted
merely for wishing it,
if every tool performed every job,
if all men were omniscient and immortal,
that everything would be the same,
the same,
all powerful thing,
God and creation would never exist and
is the differences between things which
is a function of their specific
limitations that allows them to exist at
all,
but the fact that things do exist does
not mean that they should exist even if
we are willing to grant them their
necessary limitations.
Should the world exist?
Are the preconditions of experience so
terrible that the whole game should be
called off and there is never any
shortage of people working diligently
towards this end.
It seems to me that we answer this
question implicitly,
but profoundly.
When we lose someone we loved and then
grieve.
This is a very common experience.
I don't think we cried because they
existed either,
but because they are lost.
This presupposes a judgment rendered at
a very fundamental level of analysis.
Grief presupposes having loved
presupposes the judgment that this
person's specific bounded existence was
valuable,
was something that should have been even
in it's inevitably imperfect and
vulnerable form,
but still the question lingers,
why should things even loved things
exist at all?
If they're necessary limitations caused
some suffering.
Perhaps we could reserve answer to the
question of God's nature,
his responsibility for the presence of
the evil in creation,
until we have solved the problem of our
own.
Perhaps we can tolerate the horrors of
the world if we left our own characters
intact and develop them to the fullest.
If we took full advantage of every gift
we had been granted,
perhaps the world would not look
horrible
then
that was from pages 3:43 to three slash
47 from maps of meaning published in
Nineteen Ninety nine audio version
released June twelfth,
2018.
I'll read some excerpts in the coming
days and weeks.
Thanks very much.
Bye Bye.